Okay. We have a, a David Pakman show, sub
Reddit, which is one of the bigger sub reddits
of progressive independent shows. Now more
than 10,350, David Pakman show viewers and
listeners who are subscribed to the David
Pakman show, sub reddit. I told a story on
the Tuesday bonus show my first day back from
my trip, which included a visit to France
and a visit to Italy. I told a story of using
my Spanish fluency to try to communicate,
uh, with, uh, an Italian taxi driver. And
this story is like nothing that we've had
in probably years on the David Pakman show
bonus show in terms of the reaction that it
is triggered from so many people in our audience.
And a very, very funny meme was posted to
the sub Reddit, which says, ah, it's a guy
pouring coke into a Pepsi can with the headline
trying to modify my Spanish vocabulary to
speak Italian, hoping no one will notice.
Well, listen, people noticed one when I used
the word Fico, which means fixed, uh, which
of course is not a sound that j sound is not
a sound that even exists in Italian to try
to discuss with the taxi driver, whether it
was a fixed price, a trip or not. Uh, he noticed
it was not fooling anybody. Uh, but check
out the Tuesday bonus show, sign up on our
website, check out that story and let me know
what you think. People titillated disgraced,
ashamed and horrified by that story from the
Tuesday bonus show. Also from the David Pakman
show, sub Reddit, a baseball team. I didn't
get to cover this story, but it is a funny
story and interesting.
A baseball team as apologized after including
congresswoman Alexandria, a Casio Cortez,
uh, in a sort of compilation of enemies of
freedom alongside North Korean dictator Kim
Jong Moon. It's a, uh, unusual and bizarre
story which I encourage you to read, although
I didn't have time to get to it on the regular
show today. And then also from the demo, uh,
from the David Pakman show, sub reddit and
article from NPR pointing out that the Democratic
presidential field will look a lot smaller
by September. And this is something I'm actually
going to dig into in some significant detail.
Uh, next I'm going to talk about the new requirements
from the DNC to continue qualifying for debates.
And I'll talk about whether these are too
strict, not strict enough, oppressive pro
establishment, anti progressive, whatever.
Uh, but I'm, I'm glad that people on the subreddit
are following that story because it is an
important one.
Join the discussion. We have numerous moderators
on the David Pakman show, sub reddit. I like
to keep the conversation. Uh, polite, constructive,
non trolling and the moderators are doing
a really great job of managing the community,
which now has more than 10,000 of our viewers
and listeners regularly participating. Go
to David pakman.com/r e d d I t hit the subscribe
button onto 15,000 it would be great to get
15,000 subscribers to the David Pakman show
sub reddit.